now you're a serious person
uh i'm a little bit of an idiot and i'm
going to ask you some dumb questions
uh so i do uh i do martial arts uh
so like jiu jitsu great i've wrestled my
whole life
so let me let me ask the question um
you know like whenever people learn that
i do any kind of ai or
like i mention robots and things like
that they say when am i going to have
robots that um you know that can
win in a wrestling match or in a fight
against the human uh so we just
mentioned sitting on your butt
if you in the air that's a common
position jiu jitsu when you're on the
ground you're
your down opponent um like what
how difficult do you think is the
problem
and when will we have a robot that can
defeat a human in a wrestling match
and we're talking about a lot like i
don't know if you're familiar with
wrestling but
essentially um not very
it's basically the art of contact
it's like it's because you're you're
you're picking contact points
and then using like leverage like to uh
off balance to to trick people
like you make them feel like you're
doing one thing
and then they they change their balance
and then you switch what you're doing
and then
results in a throw or whatever so like
it's basically the art of
multiple contacts so awesome that's a
nice description of it
so there's also an opponent in there
right so so if very dynamic
right if you are wrestling a human
and are in a game theoretic situation
with a human
that's still hard
but just to speak to the you know
quickly reasoning about contact
part of it for instance yeah maybe even
throwing the game theory out of it
almost like uh yeah almost like a
non-dynamic opponent
right there's reasons to be optimistic
but i think our
best understanding of those problems are
still pretty hard
i have been increasingly focused on
manipulation partly where that's a case
where the contact has to be much more
rich
um and there are some
really impressive examples of of deep
learning
policies controllers that um
that can appear to do good things
through contact
we've even got new examples of of
you know deep learning models of
predicting what's going to happen to
objects as they go through contact
but i think the challenge you just
offered there
still eludes us right the ability to
make a decision based on those models
quickly
you know i have to think though it's
hard for humans too when you get that
complicated i think probably
you had maybe a slow-motion version of
where you learn the basic
skills and you've probably gotten better
at it and and
um there's there's much more subtlety
but it might still be hard to actually
you know
really on the fly take a you know model
of your humanoid and figure out how to
how to plan the optimal sequence that
might be a problem we never solve well
the rep
the i mean one of the most amazing
things to me about
the we can talk about martial arts uh we
could also talk about dancing
it doesn't really matter too human
i think it's the most interesting study
of contact it's not even the dynamic
element of it
it's the like when you get good at it
it's so effortless like i can just
i'm very cognizant of the entirety of
the learning process
being essentially like learning how to
move my body
in a way that i could throw very large
weights around effortlessly
like and i can feel the learning
like i'm a huge believer in drilling of
techniques
and you can just like feel your i don't
you're not feeling
you're feeling um sorry you're learning
it
intellectually a little bit but a lot of
it is the body
learning it somehow uh like
instinctually and whatever that learning
is
that's really i'm not even sure if
that's
equivalent to uh like a deep learning
learning a controller
i think it's something more it feels
like there's a lot of
distributed learning going on yeah i
think there's
hierarchy and composition yeah um
probably in the systems that we don't
capture very well yet
uh you have layers of control systems
you have reflexes at the bottom layer
and you have a
you know a system that's capable of
planning a vacation to
some distant country which is probably
you probably don't have a
controller a policy for every possible
destination you'll ever pick right um
but there's something magical in the in
between
and how do you go from these low-level
feedback loops to something that
feels like a pretty complex set of
outcomes
you know my guess is i think i think
there's evidence that you can plan at
some of these levels
right so uh josh tenenbaum just showed
it
in his talk the other day he's got a
game he likes to talk about
i think he calls it the pick 3 game or
something
where he puts a bunch of clutter down in
front of a person
and he says okay pick three objects and
it might be a
telephone or a shoe or a kleenex box or
whatever um and apparently you pick
three items and then you pick he says
okay pick the
first one up with your right hand the
second one up with your left hand
now using those objects those now as
tools pick up the third object
right so that's down at the level of
of physics and mechanics and contact
mechanics that
that i think we do learning or we do
have policies for we do control for
almost feedback but somehow we're able
to still i mean i've never picked up a
telephone with a shoe and a water bottle
before and somehow
and it takes me a little longer to do
that the first time
but most of the time we can sort of
figure that out so
yeah i think the amazing thing is this
ability to be flexible
with our models um plan when we need to
use our well-oiled controllers when we
don't
when we're in familiar territory
having models i think the the other
thing you just said was something about
i think your awareness of what's
happening is even changing as you as you
get
as you improve your expertise right so
maybe you have a very approximate model
of the mechanics to begin with and as
you gain
expertise you get a more refined version
of that model you're aware of
of muscles or or balance components that
you
just weren't even aware of before so how
do you scaffold that
yeah plus the fear of injury the
ambition of goals of excelling
and uh fear of mortality
let's see what else is in there as the
motivations uh
uh overinflated ego in the beginning uh
like and then a crash of confidence in
the middle
all of those seem to be essential for
the learning process
and also and if all that's good then
you're probably optimizing energy
efficiency
yeah right so we have to get that right
uh so um
you know there was this idea that you
would have
robots play soccer better
than human players by 2050 that was the
goal
uh world basically was the goal to beat
world champion team to become a world
cup
be like a world cup right level team so
are we gonna see
that first or um a
robot if you're familiar there's an
organization called ufc
for mixed martial arts are we gonna see
a world cup
championship soccer team out of robots
or a ufc champion mixed martial artist
uh that's a robot i mean it's very hard
to
to say one thing is a harder one some
problems harder than the other what
probably matters
is um who
who who started the organization that
that i mean i think robocup has a pretty
serious following and there
is a history now of people playing that
game learning about that game building
robots to
play that game building increasingly
more human robots it's got momentum
and so if you want to uh to have mixed
martial arts compete you better start
your
start your organization now right um i
think almost independent of which
problem is technically harder because
they're
both hard and they're both different
that's a good point i mean
those videos are just hilarious like uh
especially the humanoid robots trying to
um
trying to play soccer i mean they're
kind of terrible right now
i mean i guess there is robo sumo
wrestling there's like the robo one
competitions
um where they do have these robots that
go on the table and basically fight so
maybe i'm wrong
maybe first of all do you have a year in
mind for
uh robocup just from a robotics
perspective
it seems like a super exciting
possibility
that um like in the physical
space this is what's interesting i think
the world is captivated
i think it's really exciting it's um
it inspires just a huge number of people
when
a machine beats a human
at a game that humans are really damn
good at so you're talking about chess
and go
but that's in the in the world of uh
digital i don't think
machines have beat humans at a game in
the physical space yet
but that would be just you have to make
the rules very carefully
right i mean if if atlas kicked me in
the shins i'm down
and uh you know and and game over so
there's you know it's it's very subtle
on yeah i think that's a fair i think
the fighting one is a weird one yeah
because uh
you're talking about a machine that's
much stronger than you but
yeah in terms of soccer basketball all
those kinds of soccer right i mean as
soon as there's contact
or whatever and there's there are some
things that the robot will do better i
think
if you really set yourself up to try to
see
could robots win the game of soccer as
the rules were written
the right thing for the robot to do is
to play very differently than a human
would play it's you're not going to get
you know the perfect
soccer player robot you're going to get
something that
exploits the rules exploits its super
actuators it's super low bandwidth um
you know feedback loops or whatever and
it's going to play the game differently
than you want it to play yeah
um and it i bet there's ways there's i
bet there's loopholes
right we saw that in the in the darpa
challenge
that that it's very hard to write a set
of rules that someone can't find
a way to exploit
you